my pillow ceo and founder mike lindell
known to us as pillow the guy who wants
to sue the machines we're doing a class
action lawsuit against all machines he
spoke outside the trump rally in ohio
remember his phone was recently seized
by the fbi at a hardy's drive-through
pillow is potentially in very serious
trouble legally we looked at the search
warrant last week
he spoke for almost 90 straight minutes
outside the trump rally
and
his brain is mush his brain is much
check this out i was in georgia on
november i mean on uh
january 4th of 2021 and i was down there
at that big rally for the two center
runoffs right
and i said i all of a sudden i started
praying i go god please let them take
both of these senators
and you're going okay mike you did it no
okay
the reason i say that i'm a marketer and
i'm going if i was if i was working for
that evil i would say
give them back one of these senators so
they shut up about the election
okay
had they done that maybe not you guys
but most of the people in this country
would have said my clerical guys we
still understand that we got we'll get
him back in 2022.
okay any idea what he's talking about
anybody well i got news for you there
wouldn't have been a 2022 movement it
would have been over if they would have
been smart and just give one back but
instead you all know exactly where you
were when they stole them both right and
everyone's going
now what are we going to do maybe there
was election crime you know people that
were on the fringe are all going you
know 100 million people in this country
win now what
yeah so not making a lot of sense is
mike pillow
and then last clip here as you might
remember again it was the fbi who
executed the search warrant on pillow
took his phone and so on and so forth
now he says he will be suing the fbi for
the violation of basically the entire
bill of rights listen to this
okay
my lawyers and i got together the last
couple days we got together over a
hardee's i couldn't tell you what they
have
over a hardee's uh you know chicken
sandwich i guess and
on tuesday we're suing the united states
government and the fbi
we're soon
for violating our first amendment raise
our fourth amendment rights our fifth
amendment rights
the more amendments he mentions
the more the crowd cheers the lawsuit
um really amazing i mean truly truly
incredible stuff
and this guy's in serious trouble he
really is i mean and we you know we like
to joke about pillow and he was recently
all over our facebook page leaving all
sorts of comments arguing with many of
you as as some of you noticed it's all
fun and games
until the fbi takes your phone and mike
pillow could be in serious trouble and
remember he would be much better off if
he had just stuck to selling pillows and
slippers and straight jackets or
whatever he sells
uh he would be better off trump would
have been better off if he never got
involved in any of this stuff and now
it's going to be years of problems for
them but there it is a complete house of
horrors sideshow
outside and before the trump rally but
the scariest moment probably the trump
rally itself those incredibly cult-like
moments with his uh fans holding up one
finger
and if you know what that was about
let me know we're still trying to figure
it out crazy crazy times in the united
states of america
who doesn't love a good cereal the
crunchiness the sweetness it satisfies
in a serious manner but then you grow up
and now all the healthy cereals are
boring and bland and they get soggy and
this is where magic spoon comes in it is
that sweet crunchy texture you loved
from childhood with zero grams of sugar
only four to five net carbs perfect if
you're doing keto only 140 calories per
serving and packed with 14 to 15 grams
of protein magic spoon spent years
developing the recipes it's really the
only cereal on the market to get the
texture and the flavor right without the
sugar and without a ton of carbs they
have flavors like cocoa honey nut fruity
peanut butter maybe you want to go
adventurous they've got blueberry muffin
maple waffle cookies and cream or
cinnamon roll that brings back memories
i love magic spoon the whole team does
but if you don't you'll get a full
refund but i know it's about to become
your new favorite cereal you'll get five
dollars off when you go to
magicspoon.com
pacman the link is down below